- All right, everybody
(crowd cheering)
We are back with the crew
from America's Got Talent, give it up.
(crowd cheering)
- The contestants on
AGT show off many skills
other than just singing and dancing.
And quite often, those skills have to do
with wheels that spin,
it happens it's true.
And so it's time for a game
called "Spinning your wheels."
(crowd cheering)
♪ Spinning your wheels! ♪
- Alright, teams are, the winning teams,
Simon and me
versus Heidi and Sophia.
- I know already, I'm
not gonna know anything.
- We are going to try really hard.
- Okay.
- She's gonna be so mad
because we're both so competitive.
- Oh, these two are very competitive.
- [Kelly] I know.
- [Terry] Oh yeah, oh yeah.
- I am too
it's, why even play if you're
not gonna be competitive.
So Terry Cruz
host of America's got talent
has graciously agreed to
also host this game as well.
So
Terry, take it away.
- [Terry] Alright,
thank you Kelly.
Here's how this game works.
I'll ask a question that has to do
with America's got talent
and things that spin.
If you know the answer, buzz in.
If you're wrong, steals are allowed.
Heidi and Sophia are
playing to win a prize
for the left side of the audience,
- [Kelly] Okay, okay.
- [Terry] And Kelly and Simon
are playing for the right. Alright?
(crowd cheers)
- [Terry] Yeah! Here we go!
- [Simon] This is for you.
- First question:
A performer moves her hips side to side
while spinning what item?
- Hula.
Hula hoop!
- I buzzed, it did not go!
- [Terry] Wait a minute, that was lit.
- No, this oh, because
you made this not work
because this is your show!
(laughing)
- But I, they hit it first,
they did hit it first.
- What?
- It lit up
- Yes!
- Uh huh!
- They hit it first. They hit it first.
Go ahead, what is your answer?
- Hula hoop!
- A hula hoop is correct!
- [Simon] Excuse me, our light lit up.
I'm sorry.
- [Sofia] We're gonna win!
- No, I'm not taking that.
- [Heidi] Good that you guys are watching.
- I'm gonna need to
see that playback later
- Our one lit up, rewind it.
You can't change the rules.
- just for my soul.
- It's because it's not working right!
- Just for my soul I'm gonna--
- Oh now it's working.
- Oh that's so weird! That's so weird.
- There will be no more
technical difficulties now.
- It lights up now.
- Next question.
- OK yup. Next question,
a brother and sister
duo dance and, all right Simon.
- Billy and Emily.
- Wrong. Take it.
- Uh, roller blades!
- Roller blades are right!
(screaming)
Roller blades are right!
- What were their names?
What were their names?
- Wow!
- It didn't say, it
just said roller blades.
- He's asking what spins.
- I was gonna say, while wearing what
- Their names were Billy and Emily.
- Popular items on their feet.
- No, we're taking that one.
- Would it, wait Billy
and we're just constantly
winning over here.
- OK, ask the producers
what were their names?
- See, now that's personal,
it's a personal touch,
you knew their names.
(laughing)
It's nice.
- I know their names, so we won.
- This is, we are the nice
team here, we just love
- And we're the good team here.
- And we're the winning team.
- Yeah!
(laughing)
- [Terry] Next question are we ready?
- OK, OK.
- [Terry] OK, what two-wheeled vehicles
are ridden upside down within a spher--
- I don't know, oh you said two wheels
- [Terry] Two wheel within a--
- Motorcycle.
- I was gonna say--
- [Terry] Motorcycles is right!
- Yes! Yes!
- [Terry] Simon is right.
- I didn't know how hard I could hug.
- Now it's 2-1, 2-1.
- That was a tricky question.
- All right, next question.
While juggling, it's
hard to balance on this
one-wheeled bike called a what?
- Unicycle!
- [Terry] Unicycle!
All right it's tied up,
team 2, next question.
- I said "onesicle."
- No such thing, it doesn't exist.
(laughing)
- [Sofia] It counts, it counts.
- Doesn't exist.
- [Heidi] That counts!
- [Sofia] Come on, it counts.
- Well what does count
is that ours was red
and we hit it first.
(laughing)
- It's tied up, you ready? You guys ready?
It's tied up now.
- [Heidi] We have to focus, Sofia!
- Next question, not to long ago,
a bunny rabbit dunked what
round item into a hoop
on AGT?
- Um, a ball.
- Ball.
- [Terry] Oh you got, it's a ball...
- Basketball.
- It was a basketball!
Wait, how is that gonna go? She said ball.
- [Heidi] I said ball.
- [Simon] Yes, there are
lots of different balls.
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
- It was a basketball.
- What ball, it didn't say.
- But specifically he clarified
- Could've been a football, it wasn't,
- But remember, it wasn't Billy and Emily,
it was the roller blades.
- [Terry] OK, we're going
to Simon and Kelly, got it.
- Thank you, thank you Kelly.
- [Terry] All right it's 3-2. Here we go.
- [Simon] No it's 6-1.
- [Terry] Next question.
- She is cheating.
- [Terry] An ollie and
a kickflip are skills
performed by someone
like Tony Hawk on what
wheeled contraption?
- A skateboard!
- A skateboard is right!
(cheering)
- [Terry] 4-2! Uh oh.
- [Sofia] Ours doesn't ring.
- [Terry] 4-2. Next question.
- [Simon] Just concentrate, concentrate.
- Are you ready, here we go.
Simon Cowell should not try to perform
- Ride motorcycle, bicycle,
airplane, everything.
- Oh! Bicycle, yes!
- Airplane, ride airplane?
(cheering, clapping)
- Ride airplane, do anything!
- [Simon] I'm not taking that
'cause I was traumatized--
- [Terry] All right it's 3-4 right now.
- [Simon] when you say
that, I can't concentrate.
- You shouldn't be on anything.
- He was triggered, I find that cruel.
- I am traumatized.
- [Terry] No that was wrong.
I felt wrong reading that.
- He felt trauma.
- Next question. On AGT
Extreme, a disabled man
amazingly did a flip from
a ramp while seated in what
- In a wheelchair.
- In a wheelchair!
- Yes, we win!
- I didn't know that one,
I didn't know that one.
- [Terry] It's tied up!
- I saw it, I saw it, it was so crazy.
- [Terry] Wasn't it amazing?
- It was so crazy
how he like went *woosh* and
he landed perfectly I thought.
- We are tied up 4-4.
- I don't know that I'd like to watch him.
- One more.
- Oh, one more.
(horn sounds)
- Oh, last question.
- Okay.
- Concentrate.
- A team from South Korea
wowed the judges with their
spin kicks in what
martial arts discipline?
- Hint. Oh hey go ahead.
- I didn't know you were
gonna say hint, mother.
- [Terry] Ahh, it goes to you but I can
- I'm gonna say
- Now read the rest of the
- question, but
- I'm gonna say karate.
- No it needs to be something that spins.
- OK, I don't know.
- Tae kwon do, tae kwon do!
- Who told you?
- Tae kwon do!
- [Terry] I can finish the hint.
- [Simon] Someone shouted that
(ding)
- [Terry] Yes!
- [Kelly] Someone, someone gave her that.
(horn sounds)
- They did it! The winner
is Sofia and Heidi!
- [Kelly] Whatever, we know, we know.
- No, that was the audience Terry.
- What did we win, how much money?
- No, no, no, and you're
gonna go on a cheater's wall.
Of course, I'm just kidding. Of course
- [Simon] You cheated, I'm traumatized.
(laughing)
- It's true.
- We won for our people
- He is so triggered.
- Of course here on our
show everyone is a winner
so buderflys wireless
smart earbuds were designed
for long-term comfort with
a game-changing patented
material that flexes
and forms with your ears
- While you walk.
- Providing nice, see while
you walk and you listen to
your new playlist, a perfect
fit for all day and night
comfort and you're all going
home with a pair of buderfly.
Buderflys curiosity G2
wireless earbuds worth $329
(cheering)
The new season of America's
Got Talent starts tonight
on NBC, watch it.